did you guys fight a lot growing up
oh all the time yeah we our last fight
was I was 17 I remember because I had a
I had a toughest fight with him and he
gave my left cauliflower yeah he hit me
so hard my ear swelling cauliflower yeah
yeah so we were out there's you know
fighting for a while we drove on a dirt
road called the pump house it's in the
book you know as our members their last
fight and we'd always take
out-of-towners there you know kind of
country small town [ __ ] like yeah the
cops don't see you fighting in the
streets got to the pump house for you
know people are usually doing back rows
burning joints or you know anything like
that so it's some like some real country
[ __ ] right we're getting out there and
we had rules like no takedowns like just
stand up you know knock them out and you
know knock them down was this to settle
something or this sandwich I had a box
of next day installs from cutting weight
and I was making sure I'm sorry I know I
ate this half of the sub that's what I
can eat after my workout and I'll be
good to my weigh-ins and he ate it and I
told my grandma you know the grandma
don't let anyone eat it and I see Zach
with the wrapper rings they grab his
stomach this [ __ ] was good
so I started fighting like in our
grandma's kitchen and she was like
trying to break up she twirled sweet
lady like just I didn't wanted something
happen so I ended up stopping exactly
reach over my grandma powerbomb me on my
neck I like crushed my skull a bit about
bit my tongue off so like screw this
we're going out to the pump house I and
I go outside start kicking his truck
doors in he jumps in his truck I jump in
my truck we drive I already knew where
he's going to the left at the stoplight
and she had to fight this for the pump
out okay so that was always good I was
always faster than my Bob we didn't
that's the only time I really hurt Zach
in my entire life
really right hit him with this overhand
right and it kind of gave him the stanky
leg and he looked at me as like good
good hit you little [ __ ] and I was
like ah [ __ ] he kept coming and after
that fight like dude we're gonna kill
each other you know we got to calm it
down and that was
so my thought yeah because it was like
that that was that fight the words again
we both got each other there's a long
fight we're there forever I remember our
peewee football coach drove by and he
was burning a joint and so I said the
festival the next week and he's like
boys he came up to us he's and he's real
motion music boys he goes I cried when I
saw you guys fighting he goes that was
the best damn fight ever want it's crazy
[Music]